the coronavirus persists parents are now
demanding answers about
what is school going to look like this
fall nancy cordes reports from capitol
hill where experts weighed in on this
issue
yesterday dr anthony fauci
warned senators tuesday there is no
one-size-fits-all plan
for returning to the classroom it really
will
depend on the dynamics of the outbreak
in the particular location where the
school is
in new jersey where cases have dropped
public schools will reopen this fall
with students six feet apart and
teachers in masks
in western dubuque iowa rick colpitz has
crafted
three contingency plans we could
actually start face to face and move
into a hybrid or to a distance model at
any time he's the school district
superintendent
how do you know what the right thing is
to do here
the answer is i don't and what we're
doing is we're taking as much
information as we can nancy
and trying to move forward with a plan
that works for us
our district and our values this week
the american academy of pediatrics
urged a return to in-person learning
warning that lengthy time away from
school
often results in social isolation
putting kids at risk
i worry about the socialization rob
waters is a father of two in fairfax
virginia
where parents must choose this fall
between online instruction
four days a week or at least two full
days
of in-school instruction with
independent study the rest of the time
are you comfortable with
sending your kids back into the
classroom even if
there is a degree of risk involved with
that
i would have to see what the classroom
look like and if they're stacking it
what the distancing was
children need to be with other children
they cannot be isolated
but you also have to weigh the risk in
what is safe
one of the big challenges with planning
for back to school is that scientists
still don't know
exactly what the infection rate among
children
is and how likely they are to pass the
virus on
to other members of their families and
so
the nih is studying 2 000 households
right now to try to get some of those
answers but they may not know everything
in time for the fall gail
boy nancy it's the scientists still
don't know part that's very concerning
thank you very much